in the last video we discussed personal
rights all the rights that citizens of
the United States have to control their
own bodies and minds in this video we're
going to talk about political rights
which are the rights of citizens to
participate in the actions associated
with governance so what are some of
these rights first there's freedom of
association this means that you can join
a political party or a special interest
group that represents you you're not
obligated to belong to a particular
party backed by the government and you
can't be discriminated against for
belonging to a political organization
there are the First Amendment rights to
freedom of speech press assembly and
petition this means that you can share
political ideas print political ideas
assemble for political purposes like a
conference or a protest march and ask
the government to correct a wrong
without fear of punishment one of the
most important political rights is the
right to vote citizens may vote as they
choose according to the laws of their
state there's also the right to run for
public office anyone who meets the
criteria specified by the Constitution
and their state or municipality may run
for elected office without government
interference now you may be asking wait
what's the difference between political
rights and civil rights
well civil rights overlap with these
rights as well as with personal rights
because civil rights protect people who
belong to marginalized groups from
discrimination so if a society permits
some people to vote but not others based
on their race sex religion or other
characteristic that society is
infringing on the civil rights of those
citizens by denying them their political
rights so let's take a look at a few
scenarios to practice our understanding
of political rights I'll give you a
scenario and you see if you can identify
which political rate is being exercised
or violated first Parvati's best for
natalie is running for City Council she
wants to show her support so she checks
Natalie's name on the election ballot
which right did Parvati exercise if he
said the right to vote
you're correct great next up PG posts on
her social media encouraging people to
vote for the Democratic candidate for
governor an admissions officer at the
public university PG got into is the
brother of the Republican candidate he
rescinds P G's offer of admission based
on her support for the Democratic
candidate which political rights did the
admissions officer violate in this
scenario
this is a violation of P G's right to
political freedom of speech okay last
one
Spencer has been an avid hunter since he
was a kid and is interested in joining
the National Rifle Association his boss
Charles doesn't like guns and doesn't
want the Spencer to join the NRA if
Charles tries to prohibit Spencer from
joining the NRA which of Spencer's
rights would he be violating he would be
violating Spencer's right to freedom of
association which means that he can join
groups without fear of reprisal okay
that's all for now which do you think is
the most important political right that
citizens have